en un momento vital para nuestro país lo
que hace que el Reino Unido sea grande
es nuestra creencia fundamental en la
Libertad en la libre empresa y en el
juego limpio nuestro pueblo ha mostrado
inteligencia coraje y determinación una
y otra y otra vez
ahora enfrentamos
un momento importante en el mundo
causado por la agresión rusa y las
posibilidades ahora es el momento de
enfrentar los temas que están
necesitamos mejores vías necesitamos
mayor inversión mejores trabajos en cada
ciudad y pueblo en todo nuestro país
necesitamos reducir la carga sobre las
familias y permitir que la gente avance
la vida Yo sé que nosotros tenemos lo
que se necesita para enfrentar esos
desafíos por supuesto no va a ser fácil
pero podemos hacerlo
transformaremos al Reino Unido a Gran
Bretaña en una nación a la cual se
aspirecer con él salarios altos calle
seguras y donde cualquiera en cualquier
parte tenga la oportunidad las
oportunidades que merecen voy a tomar
acción hoy mismo y acción cada día para
hacer que esto ocurra
junto con nuestros aliados defenderemos
la libertad y la democracia en todo el
mundo
reconociendo que no podemos tener
seguridad aquí en casa sin que haya
seguridad en el exterior como primera
ministra
estableceré tres prioridades en primer
lugar hace que el Reino Unido trabaje en
el nuevo tengo un plan bastante usado
para que la economía crezca a través de
cortes Fiscales y reformas
recortar impuestos para recompensar el
trabajo fuerte
y permitir el crecimiento de los
negocios también crear reformas para que
el Reino Unido empiece a trabajar a
construirse y a crecer pondremos
pondremos para que las cuentas de la
energía no sean tan costosas y
aseguraremos de estar construido
hospitales escuelas días y conectividad
en internet
en segundo lugar de frente con la crisis
energética causada por la guerra de
Putin tomaré acciones esta semana para
lidiar con las cuentas de energía y para
asegurar
nuestro suministro energético en el
futuro En tercer lugar me aseguraré de
que la gente pueda recibir citas médicas
en los servicios del nhs cuanto lo
necesiten pondremos nuestro servicio de
salud en una posición mucho mejor al
cumplir
en temas de economía de salud y de
energía pondremos a nuestra energía en
el camino de un éxito a largo plazo
ciertamente hay grandes desafíos que nos
esperan
pero tan grande
el pueblo británico es mucho más fuerte
nuestro país fue construido por personas
que hacen que todo ocurra tenemos
grandes reservas de Talento de energía y
de determinación tengo la confianza de
que juntos
podremos superar esta tormenta podemos
reconstruir nuestra economía y podremos
convertirnos en la Gran Bretaña moderna
y brillante que sé que podemos hacer
esta es nuestra misión vital para
asegurar que haya oportunidades y
prosperidad para todas las personas y
para las generaciones futuras
estoy determinada a cumplir con esto
Muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]